we review the complete timeline of the
kyle rittenhouse case the prosecution
makes its dishonest and absurd closing
argument and the defense makes its last
stand i'm benchmare this is the bench
bureau
[Music]
show bench bureau show is sponsored by
expressvpn you have a right to privacy
defend your rights at expressvpn.com
the jury is currently out in the kyle
rittenhouse trial considering guilt or
not guilt that is that is the obvious
legal standard of course
and i think it's important to go back
for a walk down memory lane and retrace
how this became a national issue because
it is fascinating to see which stories
in the united states become national
stories and which ones simply do not
which crime stories become national
stories that every american must have an
opinion on and which ones just court of
space sale under the radar they are
local news stories so to take an example
kermit gosnell an abortionist from
philadelphia who's responsible for
essentially infanticide that was not a
national news story and the media
covered it as though it was national it
was not a national news story it was a
local crime story it didn't receive
front page coverage nearly anywhere
because it didn't mirror a narrative
that the media were attempting to tell
whereas kyle rittenhouse that story was
a national news story and the reason it
was a national news story if you go all
the way back is because it was part of a
broader democratic narrative that
narrative was the true threat to america
was white men who were running around
trying to shoot
people who were either black or who are
allies of black lives matter that the
conflict in 2020 was between racists and
the democratic coalition and kyle
rittenhouse was used as the face of
racism that was always an awkward
attempt it was awkward because kyle
rittenhouse had shot a guy who was a
convicted child molester had shot
another person who had a pretty
significant criminal record that shot a
third person with a significant criminal
record and all three of the people he
shot were attacking him and all three of
the people he shot were white but the
narrative had to be drawn and because
kyle rittenhouse was present
in kenosha wisconsin in the middle of a
black lives matter slashing antifa riot
this meant that kyle rittenhouse was the
bad guy remember the media spent all
2020 trying to pretend that rioters were
not in fact rioters they were simply
mostly peaceful protesters and that the
things that they were quote unquote
protesting for were good and honorable
and noble like defund the police that
was somehow a decent idea in 2020.
meanwhile the murder rate picked up in
america's major cities by 20 30 40 in
some major american cities
and
let's not pretend that this was not
pushed by the democratic party in the
middle of the campaign you'll recall in
september of 2020
joe biden put out an ad linking kyle
rittenhouse to white supremacists in
charlottesville
and frankly it seems like if kyle
rittenhouse gets acquitted he's going to
have a hell of a lawsuit on his hands
against the democratic national
committee here is the ad including kyle
rittenhouse from september of 2020.
are you willing tonight to condemn white
supremacists and militia groups and to
say that they need to stand down and not
add to the violence in a number of these
cities as we saw in kenosha and as we've
seen in portland
okay so you see that interspersed in
this in this little question
from chris wallace to donald trump in
the 2020 campaign is a picture of kyle
rittenhouse in kenosha
and linking him with white supremacists
and evil militia groups
kyle rittenhouse who was there as we
will see by all available evidence to
provide medical aid and to protect
property and his own life as it turns
out
he was linked directly by the biden
campaign to white supremacy and racism
it was all part of the broader narrative
which was that trump and anyone who was
voting for trump was secretly a racist
and sometimes not so secretly a racist
hey so peter ducey of fox news asked jen
saki about the britton house trial
yesterday at the white house and now
it's real awkward because as it turns
out rittenhouse was acting in
self-defense as it turns out rittenhouse
is not a white supremacist he's a 17
year old young man at the time of the
shooting now he's 18
who was acting in self-defense after
having provided medical aid to some of
the rioters
and jens hockey tries to dodge the
question even so she can't help but a
kind of sneer at written house
as you know closing arguments in this
particular case which i'm not speaking
to i'm just making broad comments about
his own view um there's an ongoing trial
we're awaiting a verdict beyond that i'm
not going to speak to any individuals or
this case the president has spoken to it
already and his mom now kyle
rittenhouse's mom came out saying that
the president defamed her son and that
claims uh
she claims that when the president
suggested
her son is a white supremacist he was
doing that to win votes is that what
happened
i just have nothing more to speak to an
ongoing case where the closing arguments
were just made
oh weird weird how now you have nothing
to say meanwhile because he's president
now you got what you wanted biden got
elected on the basis of a lie
that lie was that america is broadly
speaking racist and you needed joe biden
to come in and reestablish equity
and one of the key features of these
systemic racism
blanketing america was kyle rittenhouse
and now that the evidence is coming out
now gensake wants to
avoid the consequences of joe biden's
lies we'll see how that holds up in
court in a defamation trial which should
certainly take place after this one
again this is part of the broader
democratic narrative so corey bush a
black lives matter activist who's been
elected to congress and is now an
adjunct member of the squad she tweeted
out yesterday quote
when we marched in ferguson white
supremacists would hide behind a hill
near where michael brown jr was murdered
and shoot at us they never faced
consequences if kyle rittenhouse gets
acquitted it tells them that even seven
years later they can still get away with
it
so um number one i feel like i'm gonna
need like one shred of evidence from the
congresswoman that this ever happened i
feel like that would have been a
national story if there had been black
lives matter protests in 2014 and a
group of nazis had shown up on a nearby
hill and sniped into a group of black
protesters i feel like that might have
been like we might have heard about that
just a little bit i'm gonna need some
evidence like one single solitary shred
of evidence that this ever happened from
corey bush
this is like brian williams under
fighter in iraq
just
until i see a shred like any evidence at
all okay so that's a lie but then the
idea is that even if that happened kyle
rittenhouse has something to do with
that he's a white supremacist to his
what out to shoot other white people
that night
in order to harm blackness or something
but this is the narrative and because
it's the narrative it became a national
story
and the narrative always determines what
is a national story invariably
and local crime stories are white people
shot wrongly by the cops
local crime stories are black people
killing white people those are all local
crime stories white person killing black
person is a national crime story and
white person killing white person if
it's in the service the narrative of the
democratic party that's also a national
story
so bottom line is if it's in the
interest of the democratic party and a
broader narrative about systemic
american cruelty and racism then it
becomes a national news story because
the media are just the propaganda wing
of the democratic party it's the only
reason that you know about kyle
rittenhouse is the only reason that
we've spent all this time on kyle
written house it's the only reason
frankly why this prosecution was brought
because it is 100 clear at this point
that kyle rittenhouse acted in
self-defense there is there is really no
doubt i mean normally all the defense
has to do in these cases is establish
reasonable doubt
by the use of a self-defense privilege
or a self-defense defense right that's
all you have to do you have to show
reasonable doubt as to whether the
defendant acted in self-defense in this
case it is 100 clear that the defendant
acted in self-defense
not 70 not 80 not 90 100 we have it on
tape
and but again the prosecution can't let
go of it and it is a dangerous situation
when the media turns something into a
national issue and then prosecutors feel
the necessity to bring a case because of
national pressure
that is indeed akin to mob justice
it's just done
by using the the prosecutor as the tool
of the mob
if a mob arrives at a jail to hang
somebody and they make the sheriff their
tool that doesn't make it any less of a
mob
we'll get to more of this in just one
second first you know about the ring
video doorbell by now because you've
been listening to the show for quite a
while but did you know that ring makes
an award-winning alarm as well ring
alarm is a powerful affordable whole
home security system you can easily
install yourself so whether you're
running across town or across the
country this busy season you and your
loved ones can rest easy knowing your
home is protected and it's more than
just security ring alarm protects your
home from flood freeze and fire as well
plus it is much much cheaper than those
other companies for what they charge you
for one month you can get an entire year
of ring alarm with professional
monitoring right now for the best deals
of the year on ring alarm head on over
to ring.com forward slash ben again that
is ring.com forward slash ben
i use my ring alarm for a lot of stuff
my number one priority is making sure
that my family is safe so i'm constantly
checking in when i'm on the road to make
sure that my property is doing okay and
there's nobody there who shouldn't be
but also i gotta tell you sometimes i'm
just like in my house and my little baby
just runs out of my vision uh oh where'd
you go well that ring alarm helps me
track her down my ring app helps me
track down my own kids so this holiday
season deck the halls walls windows and
doors with the best deals of the year on
the award-winning ring alarm go to
ring.com
to get a great deal on a ring alarm
security kit today that is ring.com
forward slash ben go check it out right
now okay so let's go through the kyle
rittenhouse timeline here because you
can see by the way how the media made
this part of a broader narrative and why
it became a national story so here's the
new york times timeline leading up to
kyle written house they begin with the
killing of george floyd now you might
say to yourself what the hell does kyle
rittenhouse defending himself have to do
with george floyd that's a completely
separate criminal trial involving derek
shelvin by the way another criminal
trial where i truly believe that
national media sentiment played a
massive role in how that trial was
performed and how the verdict came down
i do not believe that the evidence in
even the derek chauvin trial was
sufficient to support the finding of the
jury but put that aside one trial really
has nothing to do with the other and
george floyd has nothing to do with the
shootings of anthony huber or jacob
rosenbaum or or joseph rosenbaum or any
of the other characters in kenosha
wisconsin but the new york times starts
its story of course with george floyd
because this is all part of the protest
story okay then they move forward to
august 23rd 2020 and this is what led
things off in kenosha wisconsin so
there's a guy named jacob blake jacob
blake was a black resident
who according to the new york times was
shot and seriously wounded by a white
police officer now the question is why
was he there the reason that the police
officer was there is he was called there
by jacob blake's ex-girlfriend and jacob
blake's ex-girlfriend had called the
cops because he showed up at the door he
was not supposed to there was a
restraining order against him
she had previously reported alleged rape
against jacob blake
okay so the police show up
and they tried to take him into custody
on an outstanding war and issued in july
on charges of third degree sexual
assault criminal trespass and disorderly
conduct blake fights the cops and then
he has a knife and they tell him to put
down the knife repeatedly and then he
doesn't so they shoot him
and here's tape of that particular
incident
[Applause]
right this was the story and people are
shouting and screaming
okay so here's the thing the media
immediately covered this is another
wrongful shoot because the media were in
search of the narrative the narrative
was police everywhere are racist and
horrible because america is racist and
horrible and so anytime there's a
shooting of a black man by a white
police officer this is evidence of
systemic racism now again even if you go
back to george floyd there's not a
single allegation that was made anywhere
in the trial there's not a single piece
of evidence to suggest that derrick
chauvin killed george floyd because
derek chovin is a is a racist
that just does not exist that was not
even alleged in the trial and yet it
became the predicate for the broader
claim that america is racist and then
that broader claim was used in order to
characterize the jacob lake shooting
and it was a bad it was a bad example
because jacob blake was a criminal who
refused to comply with police commands
and was carrying a weapon at the time
that is what they call in police
parliament's a good shoot it did not
matter the media decided to treat it as
though it was a bad racist shoot and
indicative of the broad level of
suspicion and racism that amer that
black americans live under thanks to the
predations of american police officers
each and every day
and this resulted of course in kenosha
burning
right this this is where you saw the
famous video of members of the press
standing outside burning buildings
talking about how it was all mostly
peaceful
here's some of the video from kenosha
you can see
cars being set on fire
people wandering the streets in the the
middle of the night
[Music]
videoing it it's just good times all
over in kenosha wisconsin
okay so
these burnings continue
and kyle rittenhouse shows up okay so
the the protesters began august 24th
they say protesters but what we mean
really is rioters rioters started
setting fire to cars looting and burning
buildings and knocking over street lamps
okay and kyle written house shows up on
august 25th
and we have video of exactly why kyle
writtenhouse was there
a contra the prosecution's claimed that
he was there to shoot people kyle
writtenhouse explained again this is
before the shooting richie mcginnis was
the was the reporter on scene
asking rittenhouse why he was there this
is before the shootings occurred and
here is kyle rittenhouse explaining
so people are getting injured
and our job is to protect this business
and part of my job is to also help
people if there's somebody hurt i'm
running into harm's way that's why i
have my rifle because i need to protect
myself obviously but i also have my med
kit
we're protecting from the citizens and i
just got pepper sprayed by a person in
the crowd
so
so you guys are full and ready to defend
the property
yes we are now if i can ask can you guys
step back medical ems right here
okay so he was pepper sprayed didn't
shoot anybody he's asked are you there
to defend the property he says yes
because the prosecution tries to make it
out he's going to shoot anybody who
threatens the property but he literally
says in the prior sentence that if
somebody threatens him with non-lethal
force he can't shoot them right he
he immediately says that
okay so this is all the predicate to the
actual events of that night and the
reason we're going through this in
detail is to demonstrate how this didn't
fit into the media narrative but he had
to be prosecuted anyway because the
narrative matters more than anything
else this is why when people say that
the media lying what difference does it
make what difference does it make if we
just create these
broad narratives from false
circumstances the answer is it makes a
hell of a lot of difference for
individuals like kyle rittenhouse who
ends up wrongfully wrangled into a legal
trial for his life
based on non-existent evidence because
the narrative matters more than the
actual evidence it's more of this in
just one second first
let's talk about the simple fact that
right now there are a lot of jobs to
fill like lots of jobs to fill whether
we're talking about the holiday lighting
installer or the advanced snow maker or
the mall santa photographer well if you
need to hire for one of these festive
roles for the holiday season or any of
the others there's only one place you
should go zip recruiter.com dailywire
after all if zip recruiter can fill an
advanced snowmaker position and you know
that was a thing they can most likely
help you with your hiring needs how does
a zipper critter make the magic happen
well they use powerful technology to
find and match the right candidates with
your job then zip recruiter proactively
presents these candidates to you you can
easily review these recommended
candidates and invite your top choices
to apply for your job that encourages
them to apply faster no wonder zip
recruiter is the number one rated hiring
site in the united states based on g2
ratings in fact zip recruiters
technology is so effective that four out
of five employers who post on zip
recruiter get a quality candidate within
the very first day and right now you can
try zip recruiter for free at
zippercrew.com dailywire discover hiring
joy with zip recruiter just jingle your
way to ziprecruiter.com
dailywire go check them out right now
alrighty so
all of this leads up to the actual
shooting so the night of the shooting
there's a fire
and
there are many fires in the city and
in the middle of the fires
rittenhouse runs over to the fire and on
the way he's confronted by rosenbaum
joseph rosenbaum joseph rosenbaum is a
career criminal he's a child molester
and he's a convicted child molester and
joseph rosenbaum is acting crazy all
night long
according to witness testimony he
literally said if i find you alone i
will kill you to written house earlier
in the evening
so this is not a guy who is out there
doing good
he's a
a crazy person and a dangerous person he
was swinging chains he was lighting
things on fire
he was using the n-word so the only
person in this trial by the way who
there's any evidence was a racist is
actually joseph rosenbaum okay and uh
and then
there's a confrontation where rosenbaum
apparently accosts written house and
written house seeking to avoid the
conflict even though he's the guy with
the gun
starts to run away
he's running away another man
starts chasing him and that man fires
into the air
all that written house knows that
somebody's fired into the air he turns
around and suddenly rosenbaum is right
on top of him grabbing for his gun and
so he shoots him that is what this
video footage demonstrates it again is
about as clear-cut as video footage is
gonna get it's pretty rare that you have
contemporaneous video in a circumstance
like this but you do
a man who police identified as
rittenhouse runs across the parking lot
of an auto service shop followed by a
shirtless man who was later identified
as joseph rosenbaum
moments later shots ring out
and the shirtless man falls to the
ground
a figure who appears to be written house
continues running
seconds later he comes back into view
and bystanders arrive to help the victim
britain house can be seen standing by
the body making a phone call
as more people arrive he runs away out
of frame and someone seems to be heard
saying i shot somebody
so he's calling the police he's calling
for medical help and he's calling the
police
okay and the reason he starts running
away is because other antifa rioters
start showing up and he thinks to
himself okay they're going to attack me
which is exactly what happens they start
chasing him okay so the next video
you'll see is rittenhouse running down
the street
and uh and falling down as he's running
and then he's attacked by several people
one of whom he does not shoot he just
sort of brandishes his weapon at the
person who's trying to attack him a
second person anthony huber will attack
him with a skateboard and he will shoot
him and anthony huber will will be shot
dead and then a third person gage
grosskroot will run up to him unholster
his weapon start raising the weapon at
kyle rittenhouse and rent house will
shoot him that's what this video shows
[Music]
okay and then rittenhouse gets up and he
starts walking toward the police and
toward safety
so that's the case
and it is not as though this is wildly
unclear gage gross croots was one of the
people who was shot right he was shot in
the bicep
and the original story is that he was
shot
but the prosecution suggested that he
was shot because he was just kind of
standing there right that his his gun
had fallen out of his pocket or
something he lied to the cops he told
the cops the reason that his gun was out
is because it had fallen out of holster
it's not true you have video evidence
it's not true here's gage grosskroot's
admitting on the stand
understand
that
he had unholstered his gun and was
trying to point the gun at written house
whenever he shot him that is like
point blank a case of self-defense
it wasn't until you pointed your gun at
him
advanced on him
with your gun now your hands down
pointed at him
that he fired right
correct
correct and if you continue that clip
what you will see is the prosecutors
with their with their face in their
hands because they realize their entire
case is a big nothing it is a big
nothing and so the media had to look for
some alternative rationale for why this
case had collapsed they tried to blame
written house for crying on the stand
greenhouse got up his his lawyer was
asking him questions about what happened
that night rin has had a bit of a panic
attack on the stand
once i take that step back i look over
my shoulder and
mr rosenbaum
mr rosenbaum was now running
from
my right side
um
and i was cornered from in front of me
with
mr zaminski
and there were
okay and naturally the media treated
this as evidence of his guilt not
evidence of his innocence all right so
that brings us to the closing arguments
and we'll get to those closing arguments
in just one second first let's talk
about a simple fact if you're a
homeowner who's been focused on your
budget focused on your future focused on
finding the right option to save money i
have something for you to consider a
mortgage refinance it's a strategic
approach it makes sense for a lot of
people because rates right now are near
all-time lows they're not going to stay
in your all-time lows for long the
reality is that with inflation setting
in the chances are very strong that the
fed tapering is going to mean higher
mortgage rates at some point in the near
future making now the best time to call
american financing learn about custom
loan options that can save you up to a
thousand bucks a month that is correct
every month because they do more than
just lower your rate they look at your
entire financial picture finding every
way to help you save there's no pressure
no obligation no upfront or hidden fees
so why not learn more they'll give you a
free mortgage review you can skip two
payments if you choose to move forward
pre-qualify for free by calling
seven two 866-721-3300 thirty three
hundred or visit americanfinancing.net
again that's
americanfinancing.net and mls one eight
two three three four mls
consumeraccess.org
americanfinancing.net or give them a
call at 866-721-3300
so closing arguments happened yesterday
this is preceded by the judge in the
case dropping the the
charge the gun charge against kyle
rittenhouse according to abc news
rittenhouse was 17 when he shot three
people killing two with a semi-automatic
rifle on the streets of kenosha
wisconsin during a protest against
police brutality last year i love how
they they characterized that not a bunch
of people running around rioting it was
just a protest against police brutality
prosecutors brought multiple charges
against him including first-degree
intentional homicide attempted homicide
reckless endangerment and the firearm
possession count
with legal experts saying prosecutors
struggled to counter the illinois man's
claims of self-defense the best bet for
a conviction looked like the gun charge
but written house defense team dug up an
exception to the prohibition judge bruce
schrader dismissed the count monday just
hours before the jurors got the case
under wisconsin law anyone under 18 who
possesses a dangerous weapon is guilty
of a misdemeanor punishable by up to
nine months behind bars
on its face convicting the written house
on that count looked like a legal slam
dunk because he was 17 years old and
obviously had the rifle strapped to his
chest before the shooting but written
house attorneys seized on a subsection
of wisconsin law that states the ban on
minors possessing dangerous weapons
applies to miners armed with rifles or
shotguns only if those weapons are
short-barreled
that language stems from a bill then
republican governor tommy thompson
signed in 1991.
lawmakers were trying to find ways to to
curb a gang violence around that time
the goal was to prevent youths from
carrying sawed-off shotguns
the ar-15 was not short-barreled
they asked traders to dismiss the
possession counts on those grounds at a
pre-trial hearing in october
the judge refused to toss the charge at
that point
and then um he
did toss the charge
because
again the law is pretty specific
i mean the law says that you're not
allowed to carry a short-barreled
shotgun or short-barrelled rifle
but
it does not include these i mean if
you've drawn the law that way that is
what the law is
so that that charge was ruled out by the
judge immediately so basically you are
now down to the reckless endangerment
charge reckless endangerment would be
essentially shooting a gun in a crowded
place knowing that it might hit somebody
but that is going to be obviated by
self-defense in this particular case
legally speaking so the prosecution has
nothing and they they really
demonstrated that they had nothing
yesterday it was a bad closing argument
for the prosecution
so the prosecutor the chief prosecutor
here's a guy named thomas binger bringer
made a mockery of himself throughout
this trial
i mean so much so that earlier in the
trial
the the judge reamed
bingor for for being bad at his job
bingo literally attempt i mean he almost
attempted to get a mistrial declared
through his own activity
and he realized things were going so
badly that it's almost hard to read this
as anything except for him attempting to
get a mistrial he suggested in open
court that written house not talking to
the cops was an admission of guilt
which has not been the case
pretty much ever in common law and
certainly has not been the case in
american case law for something like 40
or 50 years here is the judge dreaming
binger earlier in the trial you are
already you were i was
astonished
when you began your examination by
commenting on the defendant's post
arrest silence that's basic law it's
been basic law in this country for 40
years 50 years i have no idea why you
would do something like that i said i
had heard nothing in this trial to
change any of my rulings so why
testimony on it pardon me that was
before that
get brazen with me you're an experienced
trial attorney and you're telling me
that when the judge says i'm excluding
this you just to take it upon yourself
to put it in because you think that
you've found a way around it come on
okay so it was a it was a rough road for
the prosecutors here and they just
demonstrated again i don't know where
they got their law degrees uh bingo i
think went to university of michigan law
school which really does not speak
highly of university uh of michigan for
sure okay so yesterday he
just made a mockery of himself it was
truly a terrible closing argument he
began by saying something just patently
false okay which is if you bring a gun
to a situation and then somebody attacks
you and you shoot them this means that
you do not have the defense of
self-defense available to you
that's not true in any way shape or form
if i bring a gun to an area where i'm
legally allowed to bring a gun even i
bring a gun to an area where i'm not
legally allowed to bring a gun you might
get me on a gun charge but if somebody
attacks me with a knife and i shoot them
that is still self-defense if somebody
attacks me without a knife and i shoot
them that is still self-defense
depending on if i am in legitimate and
reasonable fear for my life here is
bingo just completely botching the law
again did he send like cracker jack box
tops into the into the bar association
to get a law degree i don't understand
how this guy is even practicing
and one of the things to keep in mind is
that when the defendant provokes the
incident he loses the right to
self-defense
you cannot claim self-defense against a
danger you create
that's critical right here the defendant
decided to pull the trigger on his ar-15
four times
that was his decision
and he is responsible for every bullet
that comes out of that gun
so it is true that if you provoke a
confrontation you cannot then use
self-defense that part is true but he
literally said there's a direct quote
you lose the right to self-defense when
you're the one who brought the gun
nope
false
actively false so the prosecution's case
relies on the idea that written house
started a fight essentially with joseph
rosenbaum and that everything that there
upon followed was written house's fault
but there's no evidence that that's the
case
okay and and so instead you see the
prosecutor making just i mean bingo was
just bizarre here he was defending
joseph rosenbaum joseph rosenbaum spent
the evening
being totally insane spent the evening
burning things threatening people with
chains literally saying according to
witness testimony that he would kill
rittenhouse if he found him alone
and bingor just decides that the only
way to prosecute rittenhouse is to
pretend that joseph rosenbaum was
actually like a wonderful dude so here
he is clip 14 explaining that joseph
rose's mom really didn't do anything
that night he just you know it's just a
non-threatening kind of silly idiot
little guy who who really you know there
was nothing to fear from joseph
rosenbaum while he was like threatening
people with chains and burning cars and
such
he just happens to stumble into it
so what does he do that night
oh let me tell you all the awful things
joseph rosenbaum did he tipped over a
porta potty
that had no one in it
he swung a chain
he lit a metal garbage system dumpster
on fire
oh and there's this empty wooden flatbed
trailer that they pulled out in the
middle of the road and they tipped it
over to stop some bearcats and they lit
it on fire
oh and he said some bad words he said
the n-word
what the hell is wrong with this guy
like really i don't know what's wrong
with him and by the way all of the
offenses that he mentions before the
n-word offense which by the way
according to the media is the gravest
defense in american public life if you
use the n-word we bar you from public
society we basically brand you and say
that you are no longer allowed to
participate in public society in america
he's like well he said the n-word and
that and
but also like all the other stuff that
you're saying is criminal okay sexual
criminal activity it's like so he was
rioting so he was burning things so he
was setting a barricade to break the
cops from getting in so he's i mean was
that that big a deal like he seems like
a nice guy who was he just said he's
like a bad night how many times have you
just been walking down the street and
you said a metal dumpster on fire tipped
over a porta potty started waving around
chains shouting the n-word and tried to
block the cops from coming happens all
the time happens all the time
that's the prosecutor you remember
prosecutors are supposed to be angry at
people for violating the law that's kind
of their job it's like well his
violations of law are no big deal and
then he goes even further he suggests
that this is a mob of heroes now you
watched the tape did that look like a
mob of heroes to you the people chasing
kyle rittenhouse did that look like a
group of people out for justice that
evening or did that look like a bunch of
people who are out to make trouble and
burn things and create violence and
havoc
and did it look like they were chasing
down kyle rittenhouse to beat the living
hell out of him like before the shooting
remember he's being chased
by rosenbaum and other people before he
shoots anyone literally for not doing
anything
so here is um here's the prosecutor
trying to make the case that this is a
group of heroes who are going to believe
the narrative of your own eyes
we've had several police officers
testify that an active shooter situation
their first
instinct their first training is to go
in and stop the threat
they don't sit there and wonder well
maybe it was self-defense i don't know
i'm gonna you know let wait and see
and every day we read about heroes that
stop active shooters
that's what was going on here
and that crowd was right
and that crowd was full of heroes
that crowd was full of heroes
the actual f
what in the world
and gets worse from here by the way
bingo decided it'd be a great idea to
point a gun at like the entire room
so number one he is violating pretty
much every standard of gun safety right
now
like there are pictures of written house
walking around in the middle of the
riots and obeying the basic rules of gun
safety like don't have your finger
inside the trigger guard
here is bingo with i mean it's like alec
baldwin over here
he's pointing an actual ar-15
style weapon
at the jury
because guns are scary guys and if kyle
rittenhouse had a gun and guns are scary
that means he's guilty in some way and
he's got his finger inside the trigger
guard
like
but
what
i'm sorry this guy's a mockery he's a
mop and then and then his deputy shows
up his deputy prosecutors get him james
krause and honest to god if this guy if
this guy bingo got his law degree from
from the university of cracker jack
boxes
then james grouse the ada apparently got
his degree from like a special k mail-in
game because my god he then makes the
case that rittenhouse should have fought
these people with his fists
he says that if somebody attacks you
with their fists they're obviously not
going to do anything deadly to you so
you're a coward if you shoot them if
they're trying to beat the hell out of
you with a skateboard you have to take
the beating
clearly if there's provocation
he's guilty but even outside of
provocation
why do you get to immediately just start
shooting
as mr binger said he brought a gun
to a fist fight
and he was too cowardly to use his own
fists to fight his way out
okay so a few things i noticed that he
brought a gun to a gun fight considering
that gage gross which was showing up
with a gun
also he brought a gun to a being smashed
in the face with a skateboard fight also
he brought a gun to a somebody grabbing
for his gun fight
since i have a question since when an
american law is the rule that if
somebody threatens your life with not a
gun you are not allowed to use a gun to
protect your own life when is that the
rule in american law ever this is a real
bad day for the prosecution the defense
by contrast had a pretty easy day
because all they had to point out is the
obvious this is a political case here's
the defense attorney mark richards
making the point that this is a
political case which it clearly was
ladies and gentlemen
this
is a political case
we can take politics out of it as in
democrat and republican
but the district attorney's office is
marching forward with this case because
they need somebody to be responsible
they need somebody
to put
and say we did it he's the person who
brought terror to kenosha kyle
rittenhouse is not that individual
the rioters
the demonstrators who turned into
rioters
those are the individuals
who bring us forth
okay that is correct okay and then
richard says very controversially that
he's glad he shot joseph rosenbaum
well i mean i don't know about being
glad that anybody got shot but if
somebody's grabbing for a gun
and they get shot that is the
predictable result of grabbing for
somebody's gun
kyle shot joseph rosenbaum to stop a
threat to his person and i'm glad he
shot him because if joseph rosenbaum had
got that gun
i don't for a minute believe he wouldn't
have used it against somebody else he
was irrational
and
crazy
okay and not just that richards then
says that it's impossible
bingo had said it was impossible for
rose and moms who have threatened
written house that's of course untrue
and richards points that out
we showed the video to start this
clearly depicting mr rosenbaum standing
there at car source two
shortly after the dumpster standing
there with his chain
the shirt tied up over his head but mr
bigger says it's impossible for him to
have threatened my client that's garbage
just like his case
and then richards concludes by saying
that binger apparently lives in fairy
tale land because he's just making up
stories
this active shooter bs is something that
mr binger is trying to sell you people
has he shot anybody since car source
three no he hasn't he's running to try
and get to the police
mr binger must live in fairy tale land
to think that kyle could stop
put his gun down and say hey
everything's good leave me alone i'm
going to the police
unfortunately
that's not how the real world works
alrighty so in just one second we'll get
to the media's final take on this
particular situation because
at a certain point you have to imagine
that they want the riots
mischaracterizing the cases poorly as
they have done throughout this case
demonstrates they want something out of
this and apparently what they want is
more violence and more unrest because
the narrative uber alice the only thing
that matters is the narrative we'll get
to that in just one moment first
i own bitcoin i own some ethereum i'm a
big fan of cryptocurrency the reason i'm
a big fan of cryptocurrency is because
you can watch as the government screws
around with the monetary supply and you
can watch as the value of the dollar
continues to drop
the reality is that centralized
government are not the people that i
trust with stores of value and that is
why i believe in bitcoin and i think
that if you want to check out bitcoin a
great way to do that is with an alto
crypto ira you can trade crypto like
bitcoin and avoid or defer the taxes get
into investing in crypto do it in a tax
advantaged retirement account alto's
crypto ira is the easy way to get crypto
into an ira you can trade all you want
without the tax headache create an
account in just a few minutes invest
with as little as 10 bucks no setup
charges secure trading 24 7 through
alto's integration with coinbase i've
got 80 plus coins available including
bitcoin ethereum and cardano if you want
some sushi swap with your bitcoin no
problem alto has you covered industry
leading security they've got advanced
encryption standards for wallets and
private keys multiple ways to fund your
account you can make a cash contribution
transfer cash from an existing ira or
roll over an old 401k you can open an
alto crypto ira account with as little
as ten dollars just go to altoira dot
com slash ben and that's
a-l-t-o-i-r-a-dot-com
and go to alto ira dot com slash ben all
right we're gonna we're gonna get some
more in just one moment first
it is no secret at this point that the
left is attempting to force compliance
across the board whether it's the media
lying to push the left narrative over
the course of the written house trial or
the federal government attempting to
enforce vax mandates on employers it's
patently obvious compliance is the goal
why well because the left wants
compliance from you they want you to
just obey what they say we don't want
you to do that we would like for you to
still have liberty and freedom which is
why here at the daily wire we are
fighting every day against tyranny from
our honest coverage of the written house
trials of the lawsuit we've taken out
against the biden administration for
their unconstitutional tyrannical vax
mandate we are applying the pressure and
we're already creating change the fifth
circuit court of appeals issued a
temporary stay preventing biden's
mandate from going into effect setting
grave statutory and constitutional
issues but biden is determined to push
these mandates forward anyway we can't
let our guard down we have to continue
marching forward and we're not just
fighting for our own employees obviously
when we file lawsuits against the bind
administration we're doing so on behalf
of employees everywhere it's important
right now that everybody's voice is loud
it's an urgent matter your freedom
depends on it if you want to support our
fight to make your personal medical
decisions without governmental
interference sign our petition against
biden's authoritarian mandate hundreds
of thousands of americans have already
signed the petition but we need many
more people to stand with us to reach
our goal of one million so please head
on over to dailywire.com
do not comply to sign the petition today
you're listening to the largest fastest
growing conservative podcast and radio
show in the nation
[Music]
alrighty so
as the jury considers what is going on
right now the
the media continue to press forward the
notion that
this is part of a broader
racism narrative
article from the washington post today
again it just seems like they want riots
i don't know what else to say when you
lie about the facts of a case in order
to promote a narrative that ends with
people doing violence because they say
the system is corrupt
i mean honestly this is the argument
that the left made about donald trump in
january 6. the argument that they made
is that donald trump kept saying all the
systems were corrupt if you say all the
systems are corrupt and the election was
stolen people rebel against the system
that's the argument that the left made
about january 6th but they routinely
make that argument about systemic racism
in america policing is corrupt the
criminal justice system is corrupt our
politics are corrupt capitalism is
corrupt the systemic racism narrative is
all about getting people to quote
unquote rebel against the system and
apparently justify doing so in violent
ways and so you have the washington post
yesterday here is the headline no matter
the verdict in written house trial black
residents of kenosha say justice remains
elusive
no matter the verdict it doesn't matter
if rittenhouse were even convicted they
would still say that justice is elusive
based on what jacob blake was correctly
shot
legally he was shot justifiably
what what is your evidence here and
again no one black was shot in the
written house case every single person
who was shot was white
still the washington post presses
forward with the narrative that this is
all about race quote more than a year
after his nephew was shot seven times by
a police officer paralyzing him from the
waist down justin blake takes to this
city's broad courthouse steps each
morning and makes his case for justice
he wants kyle rittenhouse the teen on
trial here for murder after he brought
an ar-15 to kenosha amid the unrest that
follows blake's shooting held to account
he wants the families of the three men
written house shot two fatally to know
that their pain matters but the thing he
wants most will not come to be there
will be no trial for the police officer
who shot jacob blake now if you just
read all that without knowing any of the
facts that we've told you about over the
course of this particular podcast and
show
then you might think that this guy is
saying things that are are not crazy but
everything he is saying is is crazy
and written house is being tried he
should not be tried because there is no
evidence but
he wants the families of the people shot
to know that he feels their pain they
were literally attacking the guy when
they were shot he wants the police
officer who shot jacob blake put on
trial jacob blake was a criminal jacob
blake was at his ex girlfriend's house
and there was a again there was a
warrant out for his arrest because
according to her he had invaded her home
and then digitally penetrated her
without her without her consent that is
called digital rape he had apparently
performed that and then he showed up at
the house again and she called the cops
and the cops showed up and he resisted
arrest and got shot for his trouble
which is you usually what happens when
you resist arrest with a weapon
and yet the washington post says black
residents want justice do they though
because if people wanted justice if this
guy wanted justice he would understand
that justice would involve not trying
the police officer
who did the right thing in shooting
jacob blake
justin blake had tears welling in his
eyes as an icy wind rose off the nearby
lake fronts i always love when the
reporters start describing in
transcendental fashion the weather it's
like and then the rain began to pour
down on his upturned face it's like a
bad movie they took something from a
young man we can never replace and he
hasn't had his day in court i'm mad as
hell said justin black
well considering that one thing that
that young man took was um
you know the consent of a woman and just
allegedly raped her digitally
and then
threatened the police officer
i'm gonna go with
the person who was the villain in that
particular case is your nephew
i mean by the way it's it is an
unbelievable thing how the entire media
jumps to the defense of jacob lake in
the middle of that i mean joe biden
called the family kamala harris went and
visited it was insane it was insane
so many are among kenosha's black
community even though few have joined
justin blake's often lonely vigil their
absence from the courthouse steps
community leaders say should not be
confused with satisfaction about how
things have gone in the city they've
just tried to channel their discontent
in other ways the shooting of blake
according to the washington post and now
30 year old black man set off mass
protests for racial justice here in
august 2020 and added to an already
febrile moment in cities nationwide
following the murder of george floyd it
also led to looting burning and upheaval
that culminated in the written house
shootings
well it didn't just lead to looting
burning and i mean just as a side effect
nope that was the effect
it was not a mass process for racial
when you burn a car lot that's not a
protest for racial justice and by the
way it's not a protest for racial
justice when you are suggesting that the
cops are racist for shooting an alleged
rapist
who's resisting arrest like but the
media want the media want their day they
i don't unders
i'm load honestly i'm load to credit
people with malice where stupidity would
serve
but this is malicious when you start
publishing articles about how black
residents of kenosha look at the
rittenhouse trial and think that racial
justice is not being done i don't know
how to given the facts that we now know
and are available to everyone i do not
know how that is not malice by the media
it is i cannot i can no longer attribute
it to stupidity i would prefer to
attribute it to stupidity i can no
longer do that this is now malice
according to the washington post as the
verdict nears in rittenhouse's trial
there's widespread frustration that the
original source of that strife remains
unaddressed attempts in the city to
confront systemic racism and police
brutality have residents say proved
underwhelming
meanwhile the trial that brought the
national spotlight back to kenosha is
that of a white man who shot three other
white men even as the officer who shot
blake rustin chusky has been cleared of
charges and resumed serving on the force
it's evidence of an unjust unfair system
said alvin owens a black community
leader and business owner this is
something black america sees all the
time but white kenosha white wisconsin
white america don't get it they don't
know what black america experiences
for a brief while says the washington
post in the summer of 2020 as americans
of all races took to the streets to
proclaim that black lives matter owens
thought that was poised to change in
kenosha he helped organize protests but
he says that awareness came and left it
was a squandered opportunity
again the narrative must be preserved at
the expense of the facts and if a few
individuals who are not guilty have to
pay the price whether it's the cop and
the jacob blake shooting or whether it's
kyle rittenhouse the left doesn't care
they're just obstacles they're speed
bumps on the road to utopia alrighty
we'll be back here later today with an
initial hour of content in the meantime
go check out the michael knowles show
that is available right now i'm ben
shapiro this is the bench bureau show
[Music]
the ben shapiro show is produced by
elliot feld executive producer jeremy
boring our supervising producer is
mathis glover production manager pawel
wydowsky associate producer bradford
carrington host producer justin barber
the show is edited by adam sciavitz
audio is mixed by mike coromina hair and
makeup is by fabiola cristina production
assistant jessica kranz the ben shapiro
show is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 2021
the trial of kyle rittenhouse comes to a
close though not before the prosecutor
can embarrass himself even more kamala
harris's allies accuse joe biden of
racism and two-time loser democrat
candidate
beto o'rourke throws his hat in the ring
for texas governor check it out on the
michael knowles show